new rules come into force today to allow
working couples to share parental leave
after giving birth or adopting new
parents can take up to 50 weeks off
between them in whatever way they choose
and get statutory pay but some critics
say the policy doesn't go far enough and
for many it won't make financial sense @
l robinson reports sorry the first
technique a love heart it's four weeks
to go for keely and graham can do that
for as long as mum wants you to but as
well as a birthing plan they now face
another choice whether or not to split
parental leave I think that is probably
not the most practical thing but it's
something that I've thought about
because my work actively talking about
it but with gray and being the main
breadwinner it doesn't work out it does
make sense for us to do that close your
eyes in with your hand in a circular
motion on your for most at the wise
hippo birthing class it's a question of
finances and just knowing what options
are on the table every parent with a
baby born from now on has the same
decision to make they can split the 50
weeks a parental leave between them in
any combination and divide up the 39
weeks of stature to pay in through our
nose close your eyes and five but new
figures indicate parents are still
confused one in four say they're unaware
of the changes nearly a third say they
don't understand them and overall
forty-one percent won't consider
dividing leave with eighty percent
saying they would if employers offered
enhanced shared options even before
birth you can nurture your baby like
Georgia and felicium who might consider
it in the future if it's paid at the
same rate well you know I'd take a nonce
then I would I wouldn't say no I
definitely think the concept is you know
is good and I mean if we look into it
more and you speech your employer I
think it's something maybe say this time
next year our babies to you in June so
maybe the last to know if you want the
idea could kickstart a culture change
within the workplace but there's concern
employers could change maternity pay as
a result i rather cynically think we
might see some of those packages
gradually being reduced or withdrawn I
think that rather depends on the take
off if in fact there's very low take-up
by men then perhaps that won't happen
but I rather suspect at me three two one
relax for women's careers and father
involvement though it does provide more
options if it strikes the right balance
financially and emotionally Adele
Robinson Sky News